at the point hold it in here comes Norris with
it four game goal streak for Norris he's the
hot s for AWI he plays it a drive chance for CH
and it just goes wide Norris has got it to the
point drive by Jer room is CH with a Chance goes
Jacob CH puts it home and Ottawa is on the board
first miss the family's in town and Jacob Cher
with a couple of real nice defensive plays on
the power play to keep the puck alive he finds
himself in the slot of this five on five play he
backs himself out then he comes back into it if
first two don't succeed try try again good shot
from the point hits the back wall chickin CH
picks it up and deposits it right back in the
net and the auttaa Senators Smith takes a shot
tipped in front by Rael Smith HS it up for lat
L back for Smith Riley Smith got it down low
scores larsell rips it home from a sharp angle
his first goal in 13 games and the Penguins tied
at one overdo a little bit with the passing this
unit here the Tang lays it over to Smith Chris
Cross and to the net there's just no doubt about
it ell sitting down low just above the goal line
and nice pass by Riley Smith and forsburg just
doesn't get over to the post quick enough you
know it's going there and you know he's going
to have to release it quickly and he he had to
stop it l Tang knocks it away comes up along
the boards to the point branstrom down for kachuk
lady kachuk tried to center it oh what a goal Josh
Norris BS it out of the air and in and ottawa's
got the lead back there's one for the highlight
reels and you get up done you know it all with
score this is a good positive shift branstrom
just gets the puck down low the big body of
kachuck there battling and as the puck bobbles
itself out in front I think Norris is going to
clip this right out of the air it goes up and
boom right there he just whacks it kind of right
across his Crest and it's through under the arm
of the delovic and the Senators Take the Lead
that's an answering goal right there you like
to see little slap pass off Miss r made it around
for p in back to Carlson over to P with a drive
off the outside of the post Jus out of the box
zo up with a puck he's going to try to get it
up to Center for clu TI it back left at his
s level carry it in leaves it for keru jeru
throws it on that bluered away by movich ch ch
curs back DPS it off tried to at least the Chuck
was down there got in the way one thing a lot of
the penguin power play guys on that first unit
has to get used to is how hard goes Brady C shot
KS it in on the soft pass from pjo and it's 3-1
Ottawa lucky break there for the Senators and then
the stretch pass to jeru and he just throws the
back head across he's throwing the puck to an
area this isn't meant to be on the stick it's
meant to have kachuck skate into it it's a very
firm play so all kachuck has to do is just lean
the stick right on it Pon in's crossbar ends
up being a senator's break and got it in Bry
kachuck jumps on it kachuck TR to go to the
net that was knocked away rley Smith will thr
out as Mel will knock it down left it for Crosby
Sydney Crosby and fr for Melly scores rard Rael
finally gets his first goal of the year and the
penguins are within one not realizing that this
is actually a two-on-one and Crosby lays The
Firm pass across onto the Stick of recel who's
on his backand just opens up the Sydney Crosby
into the corner with it plays it up for Mar
trying to get it back down low as the power
play is over kachu taking off at center now
break forwa stays on side kachuck hit by Scar
and crrom finishes the job and it's 4 two on
a how tight this actually is nice job by
Sanderson to get the puck up to branstrom
coming out of the box and he just lays it into
kachuck Eric Carlson's trying to Easter famish
who do I take which gu do I want to get on but
the Long Reach of kachuck enables him to keep
the puck out of Harm's Way from Carlson and
then he just lays it back over to branstrom
and that dragging up that back right leg I
think he's on S side let's take a crack at
this it is so close and he's dragging it and
his foot is tipped over right it's close and
what a great play the captain's had a whale
of a game this far all right we've got our
verdict here's Michael marovich after the
coach's challenge it was determined that
the play was on side therefore we have a goal
Pittsburgh will be Char a delay of game Penal
from Dow low along the goal line there a little
bit of a shot rebound on the back hand there and
forsberg does a real good job of keeping that out
of the net Pon from the line snaps it towards him
and they score Jo o Conor got his stick on it in
front tips it by forsberg and a minute 51 into
the third the penguins are within one and let's
get on this thing and we haven't played well for
two periods we could have one good period maybe
steal a point or two here as Pon throws this to
the net and it's just bodies in front you lose
the draw that's the key and and it sets up the
opportunity but Conor gets ahead of his check he
gets the chance to get across the front of the net
he doesn't get boxed out and right there Sanderson
got it ahead and it's pitch up off for Norris over
the line to to PCH uping shooting Movic with the
Stop and he'll squeeze it but he's got a pretty
good set of on him as well not just for fistic
C nice attack Doris moves it to the wing then
drives to the net Carlson at the point will keep
it in Carlson to L Zell shooting that Miss Carter
side with the in and forer got across to make the
save f withn it back to Carlson Carlson for malan
the Carlson the malan shooting forcb stop malan on
it again he'll move a little more to the middle D
it off for Carlson Carlson to Fires for but the
stop trying to get oh what a save by pord can ra
with a walker and they move it around Sullivan
makes a change he puts Malin and up to Center
and gets it in deep forberg out of he'll play it
on the corner turn it over to M loan back to the
point latain TI it across from Pon driving
it away from jaru hands it off latain with
a shot scores Chris L Tang gets one through
and the Penguins press works big tight it's
44 this is the 20th shot for Pittsburgh in
this period as L tries to stay on side gets
it over to Pon gets it back and he fires
it right through Josh Norris it looks like
Norris is providing the screen for leang
another a nice little move there by pson
to keep it alive and kachuck gets too far over
he's too far over so when the puck goes back
to the tank he's not in the shooting Lane
makes it back in the line watched by Malin
May Malin all over CH can he hold the
Zone he does can he play the Pu he do p
go k sta with a fous miracle and Ottawa wins
it 54 and overtime this could have went either
way right here B and chipper are battle and
recel decides he's going to lead on the one
side thinking this could be a breakaway
for me and instead it turns around and B
it with a nice little feed through Rael right
to stla and he waits out the delovic and lays
this into the back of the net and that is a
baby grand piano falling off the back of the
Ottawa Senators who blow a two nothing
lead get out played in the third period